I wish I would you need to be able to
make a banana we'll probably be making a
decision in January or February we're
gonna see what happens the polls have
come out they've been unbelievably
strong they say I'd win the interesting
thing about Trump is that he's been
threatening to run for president for
basically 25 years all the way back to
the 80s when he gave a speech in New
Hampshire and saw a bunch of newspapers
all over the country write stories
wondering or speculating about whether
he would run this is the first time he's
actually filed papers and is out on the
campaign trail and I think a lot of
people are surprised by that there are a
lot of reasons for Donald Trump's
popularity right now in the Republican
Party one of them I think boils down to
the celebrity effect if you look at the
polls he does best with voters who are
not as likely to vote in Republican
primaries so imagine a pollster calling
you up and reading you a list of 17
different candidates and then asking who
you support chances are Donald Trump may
be the only person you've heard of I'm
not using the lobbyists I'm not using
donors I don't care I'm really rich I'll
show you that this Trump appeals to
people's ideal of what they would do
what they were rich they would have
fancy suits and big private airplanes
and hang out with supermodels Trump's
entire persona is sort of geared toward
the dreams and fantasies of what wealth
is like for the average blue-collar
middle class worker I guess I caused
controversy and for no reason a lot of
people don't like the political
correctness rules that govern how we
talk and what we can say and Donald
Trump flies in the face of all of those
rules all the way back to his
announcement speech when he made a lot
of really crazy comments about Mexican
immigrants or when he attacked John
McCain's war service or when he got into
a feud with megyn kelly at Fox News and
suggested that during the debate she was
menstruating
he is the billionaire who doesn't play
by your rules and isn't governed by
political correctness and that's what a
lot of people like about him Mexico is
sending people that Mexico doesn't want
and everybody knows that's what I was
saying
one reason Trump gets away with saying
such outrageous ludicrous things all the
time is because Donald Trump has a
policy where he never apologizes for
anything and by virtue of never
apologizing it makes it so that people
just assume that it wasn't that big of a
deal look I'm a Republican I'm a
conservative I'm running I'm in first
place by a lot it seems forty girls a
ball can't you win the nomination sure
yeah you know yes he could win the
nomination I think most people would
still say it's unlikely if you think
back to fall of 2011 Rick Perry was
leading in the polls at that time of
course he didn't become the nominee fall
of 2007 Rudy Giuliani was leading in the
polls a lot of people that lead in the
polls at this point in the campaign
don't actually end up becoming the
nominee